okay the world watched history being  made in Japan this morning Japan's new  emperor officially ascended the throne  in an ancient ritual and for Naruhito  down donned rather a copper colored robe  like that worn by his great-grandfather  the monarch took part in a 30-minute  ceremony and even stepped up a canopy 21  foot high throne to give a speech you  received three buns I cheers from the  audience hashing him a long reign means  10,000 years long live 10,000 years now  ITA's father abdicated the throne back  in May he is the 126th emperor in the  world's oldest hereditary monarchy  interesting hairdo very cool  so the Empress Masako she I don't know  but just point out that the Empress  Masako had been in the news for  suffering from depression and anxiety  who talked about Megyn Marcos she was  worried about becoming a so high-profile  in a role so given that we have a show  about stopping the stigma even Empress's  yeah and queens and princesses have fun  every day